they sold it for 900 million dollars in
cash they don't really mention much
about the company other than it was
doing over 100 million in revenue but
they what they don't mention is the guy
who started it he bootstrapped it raised
no outside money and owned 100 of it all
the way through the sale all the way
through the sale owned 100 of it a
million dollars isn't cool you know
what's cool
a billion dollars
[Music]
so let me tell you this quick story this
was not a big headline i bet you didn't
even see it
so my friend uh i was in college at the
time he's a little bit he's older than
me so he was not in college he was
probably in his 30s when i was 21.
he started this company called linode
did you see yesterday a company called
linode was acquired for 900 million
dollars in cash
yeah who bought it it was um um
is it called akamai
oh come on yeah akkamai
and so they bought it for not the art
everything i'm going to say is is
relatively public or it's you could
piece it together in a bunch of
different articles but basically they
sold it for 900 million dollars in cash
they don't really mention much about the
company other than it was doing over 100
million in revenue but they what they
don't mention is the guy who started it
he bootstrapped it raised no outside
money and owned 100 of it
so
his name was chris he uh i knew him when
i was in college but not bad all the way
through the sale all the way through the
sale owned 100 of it
um the company all right let me give you
a little bit background i think when
they sold they had like 300 ish
employees but throughout their existence
they had a relatively small staff like
like they were doing like multiple
millions of dollars in revenue per
employee and it was it wasn't run like a
family business but almost kind of like
a family business based out of new
jersey so basically this guy what does
it do what is linode
so i'm not in this space so excuse me
but basically it's cl it's basically
like the generic term is it's cloud
computing so basically before amazon web
services was around lynnode was there
and i think some of their customers are
like walmart so they host they help host
you know applications and websites is
the is the non-techie version uh that
i'm that that i would say but what are
you looking at the website what's it say
i'm looking at the website basically
says you know clutch your cloud bill and
your cloud bill in half
um it's basically like deploy linux
servers in the cloud is the idea i think
we used this by the way at my previous
startup i remember seeing a bill for
linode probably they're they're pretty
popular but they because they were
bootstrapped they couldn't quite keep up
with like uh what's with the other
competitor i think digitalocean which is
like publicly traded now for
multi-billions but basically in the
early 2000s like 2005 or 2006 chris
worked at this company called uh
health stream which was uh
it's not important it was a boring
company and they he worked in like with
computers with tech and he he grew up
with an apple and loved tinkering with
computers but what he noticed was that
hosting was really expensive so he
basically locked himself in his
apartment uh from like 2002 to 2003 and
like had a year's worth of savings and
like locked himself in this apartment to
code and build this website and he's
like if it works it works if it doesn't
it doesn't so he launches it and right
away it does good enough to pay his
salary like single digit hundreds of
thousands of dollars by year two because
this was in early 2000's i don't even
think amazon web services was around at
this point and if it was it was like
brand new and in fact this whole idea of
cloud computing was brand new at
healthstream chris was like look we've
got to like spend all this money to buy
servers what if we just like bought a
bunch of servers and rented it out to
people and that was like the idea
because it's really hard for a small
business who doesn't want to create a
bunch of servers in their office to like
actually host a website host
applications things like that so that's
where the idea came from
and so it grew like a little bit year
over year it wasn't growing like crazy
for a long time um but it was doing okay
chris kind of was always obsessed with
automation so we did a really good job
of automating a lot of the parts of the
company
and so they could hire relatively small
staff you know like only like 10 or 15
people for the first handful of years
even when it was getting close to making
um over 10 million dollars a year still
really small and basically the way it
worked was
i don't think he ever took out a loan i
don't it was 100 self financing and so
it would make a lot of money like these
businesses can make uh on 10 million
dollars in revenue can make 4 million in
profit but in order to get to like 30
million in revenue you've got to go open
up a warehouse or rent a warehouse and
buy a bunch of servers and there was
times where like
my friends who worked there along with
chris were literally like tinkering and
assembling the servers
and they did this for years and years
and years and it and it grow it grew
nicely and they did a really good job of
like automating their customer service
even for a long time chris was answering
the customer service it grew really
quietly he's not on twitter i don't if
you google him you might find two
pictures there's basically nothing out
there about him um
he's based out of philly and he bought a
bank like uh like a physically a bank
that was the home it was a bank turned
house it was the house from the real
world philly he bought it and they did
an article about him how he was
restoring this bank and leno it was
leno's new office but he was taking a
little bit of money off the table enough
to buy a 10 million dollar bank um
but owned the whole thing and just
yesterday it was announced that it was
sold for 900 million dollars in cash
[Music]
all right and then i forgot to tell you
this but this is the most important
thing uh i can't believe we didn't talk
about this earlier to be honest with you
because if you're listening to this and
you like what you're hearing right now
and you haven't gone and subscribed to
the my first million podcast wherever
you get your podcast
then that's the thing you've got to do
there's nothing more important than
doing that right now and don't do it
because i said to do it
do it because you want to do it do it
because that's who you are
how do you know this guy you said you
knew him in college he was at your
college or you just know while you were
in college so
when i was in college um i used to work
for that show i told you american
pickers and a guy came in and he was
like i start internet companies and i
was like
oh really i like entrepreneurship that's
cool will you like just let me hang out
with you and he let me hang out with him
and this guy his name was casey he
became the he was in my wedding i became
friends with him for years and years he
was probably 35 when i was 21 or
probably 10 years older than me and
casey helped chris get linode off the
ground and was the ceo for a decade or
so
gotcha
uh wow and chris now at this point he's
got this like huge collection of b w
motorcycles so for motorcycle fans
there's like motorcycle fans is like a
sub category of like car enthusiasts and
bmw vintage motorcycle fans is a sub
category of that and chris owns i think
one vintage bmw motorcycle from every
single year ever produced and so we are
all motorcycle nerds and we would geek
out over that stuff and we would ride
motorcycles together
dude i need a white guy rich guy hobby
this is what's holding me back i realize
i need to start
[__] buying motorcycles from you know
the 19 anything like 30 years ago
and then i need to care about it and i
need to learn how to restore it and like
polish it or whatever i need to become
tim allen from home improvement and have
this like thing in my garage i'm always
working on so i can just when i meet
these guys i gotta have something to say
you got that you have that something to
say
i'm like what am i gonna say like you
know hey what's up bro you like the nba
and it's like yeah me and 100 million
other people there's nothing to get what
about
so rolex's or rare watches is one of
those if you you had to spend thirty
thousand dollars so hard to care about
these things dude why do i i can't care
about it i see it i just feel nothing
i'm dead inside yeah it sucks man you
got to get passionate about something
outside of your house
like you [__] dork like i literally
don't leave a house dude by the chef was
like hey um we need more gas for the
grill and i was like oh i was like oh
grills need gas and i was like
never grilled it i was like okay where
do i get that and she's like you know
just like next time i got a gas station
i was like
i don't really
go to run errands she's like next time
you got running errands just grab one i
gotta really go run errands
so like she's like been asking for two
months just i finally got it and i was
like so proud of myself and she's like
so did you forget every time i was like
no no i just don't really go out of my
house unless it's like for very specific
things like i'm taking my daughter to
the playground
i'm going you know to a restaurant and
back home you need a little notice
last night i went to home depot just to
walk around and look like
like in the evening i was like i've been
at home all day i'm gonna go walk around
home depot and see if like let's like
let's check out like how many home depot
workers do you know by first name
number three what you could do if you go
to home depot if you see a guy wearing
carhartt and paint on their pants you
don't even have to ask a worker you
could just ask that guy who's there
shopping that's why
he'll take an hour to help you yeah like
hey do you know where the wood screws
are yeah i got you bro like i wouldn't
even know what to ask i would just be
like hey do you know what home and where
home improvement goods are
yeah man you need to get a hobby like i
bet ben has one ben do you have ben has
one because he's like a history buff
another white which rich white guy hobby
to have is like you know studying you
know great men through history ben do
you have any other
you know very uh rapport building um
rapport building things
i don't know that i do but i don't know
if you guys have seen this but mark
andreessen has been going nuts of like
reading history books and then tweeting
about history so like
i i feel like that's your hand
yeah yeah like if i was with mark
andreessen and i could not talk about
tech
we would be on a silent retreat
it would be a silence
by the way you got to keep your camera
on because when i see you laugh i know
we're onto something
um anyway yeah you need to get a hobby
rolex is a good one a lot of people like
that if i see someone with a certain
rolex i talk to them about it um cars is
good but i have a feeling you don't even
know how to drive so i would stay away
from that i learned how to drive at age
19. so because i just wasn't interested
yeah how your wife ever
shocks me don't listen to music i only
listen to sports radio my whole life so
if somebody's like what songs do you
like i'm just like oh you know
i'm cool with whatever and they're like
oh you're a [__] weirdo huh
oh my god that's great uh yeah you need
to get a hobby dude but uh this is the
story of lenode kind of a cool story
right you never really talked about it
no that's that's awesome
[Music]